all right here we go bootleg cat podcast
we got a special guest in here my guy
for us in the building my man thank you
for having me new album Butterfly Effect
yep is out right now yes sir
um why that name because obviously we
know the movie uh yeah shout out to
Ashton Kutcher also some of us might
know the movie it's a dark movie weird
movie yeah yeah
um I just feel like it kind of in a
nutshell like everything happens for a
reason and a lot of things happen in my
life where I felt like I wanted this I
wanted that and um I didn't get those
things but at the end of the day I kind
of accepted like kind of like accepting
fate Manifest Destiny kind of thing and
um you know everything kind of just
works the way it's supposed to and I
don't feel like I'll be here right now
if all those good and bad things didn't
happen when you say you wanted certain
things are you talking about like
industry type success industry life
um you know success whether it's success
love family things
um Financial whatever it is you know we
all want those things but sometimes we
don't get them well listen man I got to
give your flowers because I know you
like have kind of been through the ring
or in the music industry you've
obviously been on major labels you've
had a career that's spanned over a
decade now
but like dude you [ __ ] are lit bro
it's [ __ ] I'm having fun with it man
it's it's a funny job I don't know if
you still have your store on Fairfax do
you no just uh okay but you had okay you
had that store for a very long time on
Friday right it was fun most of these
rappers couldn't sell a [ __ ] concert
tickets let alone have a [ __ ] a
successful clothing line right that has
a brick and mortar store on one of the
most expensive streets in [ __ ]
America yeah it's stressful man it's
it's a stressful thing to maintain it's
a big deal while maintaining a you know
music career a a brand career a business
you know I mean all those type of things
are it's stressful but you know I just
have fun with it and I just kind of you
know even the album you put out was it
in 2020 or last hour yeah yeah I would
love to yeah you did some crazy numbers
man yeah
fun I just have fun with it independent
independent [ __ ] Kaylani and Janae
and all kinds shout out to the homies
hey all the [ __ ] I hate I I
understand that like
it's easy to like compare yourself to
other people or your peers or people who
you feel like oh man I see them on you
know performing at award shows I should
[ __ ] all that bro like you've done a lot
and those are the things I'm talking
about like I I want those you know award
shows I want to be at the Grammys here
be it you know this and that but at the
same time like I'm I'm kind of just
accepting of and grateful mostly of what
I have and what's been given to me and
what I work for but um you know I feel
like not everybody has a fair chance and
some people have advantages but at the
end of the day you just kind of find you
have to find what's you know what you're
grateful for